oh my gosh
giaco
choco and jesse win okay we are back
with jennifer shaker and barbara bush
everybody
their new book is once again called the
super power sisterhood and since we're
all children of the 1980s we thought
that we would play a game sisters versus
sisters called totally rad 88 trivia
[Music]
get it jesse who is also my soul sister
my musical sister and my real sister
isn't in town so will you be my sister
today i will be your sister okay
okay
thank you we are here
at our you can come right here ma'am you
look so great in the evening
thank you
we are here in our recently renamed
nick jonas
um lectern of integrity um he took over
nick alfred's um and now we just need a
host so lord i'm looking at you hey
kelly i'm a tourist too how about that
isn't that amazing everyone awesome is
that's right now it's nice to see you as
well barbara and jenna nice to see you
don't mess with texas it is it is the
one and only the one
okay here's how this game works
i'm gonna ask a question about pop
culture of the 1980s okay now if you
know the answer you're gonna hit your
button now you can hit the button before
i'm done talking but then you're gonna
miss my sultry voice so i don't
recommend it okay you're waiting also
steals are allowed you can steal now if
jenna and barbara win their photos will
be added to the blake shelton wall of
champions who beat kelly clarkson we
here's your first question okay
what line of plush dolls would stare
down the bad guys as beams of light and
rainbows shot out of their bellies
care bears
it is care bears and i thought beanie
babies at first nope he said the second
he said stare i was like
here's the next one
okay what oscar-winning actress released
her first workout video in 1982. um um
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Applause]
i feel like
all
right
our
button
we go all right now let's get chill now
get your leg warmers on and let's uh do
our next one here we go here's your next
question
according to the band tommy two-tone in
1981 what was jenny's phone number
eight six seven five three six seven
five three or
nine we're musicians
don't sing anymore don't sing anymore
it'll cost us a million dollars okay
now here we go now kelly and jesse
you're still in the lead you got two
points jenna and barbara you got one
point come on now you can do this come
on now here is your next question
here you go who was the first woman to
be inducted into the rock and roll hall
of fame in 1987 finally earning a little
r-e-s-p-e-c-t oh i feel like i hit it
i'll read the franklin
[Applause]
and we got ourselves a tie that's what
i'm talking about okay i just need to
make sure this thing's sold believe me i
know we already needed to make sure that
works yeah it's still working it's still
working you're quick
[Music]
this is it that's your final question
and this is for double this is for
double the points this is for double the
points now okay okay so pay
the 1981 queen and bowie song under
pressure was sampled now you have to
stop right yeah go ahead
under pressure was sampled by by vanilla
ice who did eyesight's baby that is
correct
what a surprise
what a shock to no one
what
you do
you were not
because i thought you were done anyway
you're not done you don't get on the
wall
[Applause]
good game
[Applause]
don't get it
[Music]